foreign
stop what you're doing
unless you're driving don't stop don't
stop but tell everybody in the car to be
quiet
if you're vacuuming or mowing just take
a second and stop for a second
I want you to listen to this if you're
on YouTube I want you just to stop
multitasking
focus in for just a second check this
out this is from a recent talk I gave
and I'll leave it at that check it out
I know about you I know about you
and I know you're exhausted
and your kids are finally in bed
Maybe
they're playing video games and
hopefully they're making good choices
with strangers online here's the deal
it's quiet
the lights are low in the house they let
you low and when it's finally time for
bed your body commits an act of mutiny
because being an adult is trying
desperately to stay awake during the day
and trying to fall asleep at night and
you go to bed and you put on some
headphones and you listen to your murder
podcast because why do they keep coming
back to the scene or some of you put uh
like two talk show hosts that are like
the end of the world is coming and
you're like and that's your world right
and then then or you watch uh
reruns of the office are Ted lasso
because imaginary people in imaginary TV
shows are the last decent human beings
on the planet right and after a while
your eyes start Crossing
from all these screens
and your body's like I guess we're up
and so you find yourself in your
bathroom just crushing up Tylenol PM and
just snorting it off the counter
and you're not asleep but you're
unconscious
right until about 3 A.M and
your body's like we got crap we gotta
think about right now and you wake up
and then you're like I what if my
business fails what if it fails and then
you're like maybe maybe my business
would fail I don't even like my business
and then over here you're like what if
what if China invades Taiwan I know I
know it's gonna just disrupt world trade
in a way that we haven't seen it's
probably been a kickoff world war three
but I I can't do another three months of
homeschooling like covet I can't do it
right and then like hey you know that
kid that mole that mole on on Jeffrey's
back it's for sure cancer I'm I know
it's cancer and so there's one place
that we go we're gonna google it let's
Google it at 3am and try to solve this
and then while you're scrolling you
happen by your bank account balance and
your credit card balance and your
stomach drops into your feet and you
think
I'm going to have Hypersonic diarrhea
right now
and you're like how do we owe what and
then you think I could go kill
my husband and they would never find his
body because I listened to murder
podcast right and then you finally go go
to sleep and you sleep for about an hour
and your eyes pop open because of your
alarm and you drag yourself to the day
because you're Crossing it you're gonna
snap into a slim jim that I'm talking
about and you go work out and you turn
the water on the shower so hot it's
burning off your day and you get in the
shower at 7 58 for your eight o'clock
meeting
and you have a 20-minute commute and
then you get out of the shower and it's
8 40 and you are pissed at time just
kept going while you were in the shower
and then you get out of the shower
and you walk by the mirror
there's a couple of people in this room
and I've met you you just look at
yourself and you're like that's what I'm
talking about
[Laughter]
but most of you walk by that mirror and
you just stop and you're like
I don't think I believe in God anymore
right and then you start mainlining
coffee to take the edge off the Tylenol
PM you snort it all night and then your
family's running around and you're
barking conversations like hey don't
forget to pick this up you have to put
on deodorant every day every day and I
told you to do that what do you mean
that's due today and then you're like
your mom is going to stay for how long
and then you make eye contact
and you're like
and she looks at you across the room and
she's like God no we're not having sex
I'm gonna have gas tonight no
and then you go into the garage to get
into your car and one of your kids just
barfs everywhere and instead of going oh
my gosh baby are you okay are you okay
your first thought is
if I just keep walking she will clean
this up right
and then you go to work and you're
standing next to this woman
and she's like oh my gosh I heard your
Keto
keto is amazing but you can't eat bacon
because of the fat Parts have you done
ancestry 23andMe it's amazing you should
totally wear barefoot shoes because
sitting is the new smoking but my friend
Sparrow she rolls her own organic
cigarettes and because because smoking
is the new standing and let's do
somersaults right and you just think to
yourself
I don't I don't want to be alive right
now
and then at 10 30 freaking Dan rolls up
and I've got a fire Dan because Dan's
always late but Dan always
things donuts and the only thing
that takes that image burned into my
soul
of me shirtless in front of the mirror
is
carbs and sugar it just shoves that
image down into my soul right and then
I'm walking to the bathroom and I hear
this from behind me
oh no no
I'm a cat dad and I turn
and he goes
it's it's way more challenging than
being a the parent of a child and then I
think I'm gonna go in the parking lot
and just set myself on fire to see if I
still feel pain all right
and after a fast food lunch of
indigestion and insulin and diarrhea and
for those of you keeping track that's
that's diarrhea reference number two
right you have to go to this Consulting
meeting with this idiot 22 year old with
a master's degree in leadership and the
only thing he's ever LED is a little
rubber ducky around his bathtub right
and then you're staring at spreadsheets
and terrible homemade marketing
materials and you can't wait to the day
and you go get in your car and you put
on another murder podcast because how
hard is it to murder stop talking about
it after you do it and then you go home
and you sit on the couch and you and
your wife or you and your husband on the
couch and instead of talking about how
much you're suffocating under all this
debt and how your calendar is stuffed
tighter than your marketing interns
genes and the phone rings and your
mother-in-law says hey here's the next
14 years of Thanksgiving plans and you
don't want to do any of it
but if you say something to her right
there on the couch to your wife or your
husband
they're gonna kill you
and they listen to murder podcasts too
and they will never find your body
so you repeat you you you retreat
to ESPN Fantasyland
can we take a second
fantasy Sports
where grown men
use other real grown men as action
figures
in imaginary games
[Laughter]
look you were there's a husband and a
wife on a couch
playing imaginary games with the real
other men
I'll give you dragons and trolls and
stuff
no this guy lives in your same city and
he's my guy right
and she is sitting right here looking up
lion tattoos that say hashtag blessed on
her iPad and cauliflower mashed potato
recipes and she's looking at 18 year old
birthday parties your kid's nine by the
way y'all could be out absolutely doing
it right now
[Laughter]
that makes no evolutionary sense and
you're four inches apart from each other
and you're four thousand miles away
and then you snort a bunch of Tylenol PM
off the counter
this is our day this is our day this is
what we call normal this is my day this
is your day this is our life
this is insane and then we go to a
doctor we go to a doctor or a counselor
on the Internet or some therapist and we
say I'm anxious I'm so anxious I've got
anxiety I'm chronically stressed I'm
burned out and the doctor says well it
sucks to be you because anxiety is a
disease it's a genetic disorder and it's
in your brain it can only be cured with
with with medication you're always going
to have it you will always be burned out
you're always going to be chronically
stressed that's your new identity it's
who you are you have anxiety right and
so we uh go to another doctor we open
another bottle of bourbon we start
working more and more hours and more and
more hours some of you weirdos just rub
essential oils all over your body
because whatever
because you guys believe in YouTube more
than all right
lunatics so then
[Laughter]
thank you
you go see another counselor you talk to
a pastor you talk to a friend and it's
it's Madness
and you finally get the courage to say
hey I'm so anxious I can't breathe
I've got so much stress I'm on the edge
of burning out of everything
and I miss my husband
and I sit at my kitchen table once a
week when I've got all my family and I'm
surrounded by people I love and I am
deeply alone
we haven't slept together we haven't
been intimate in what feels like forever
and my marriage is crumbling and my kids
don't want to be in the same room with
me and I'm exhausted and I can't sleep
you look around and the world is
freaking falling apart
all right we're back listen is that you
are you sick and tired of being so
chronically stressed and anxious
everything's electric and listen you've
gone to all the experts you read all the
blogs
and the the way we're doing mental
health in this country is simply not
working it's not working
if this is you I got you if this is you
you're just like me
today is the first day you can pre-order
my brand new book building a non-anxious
life here it is I'm super excited about
it because
[Applause]
halfway through this book so I wrote
this book about anxiety and about
chronic stress all the stuff that we got
going on
and then halfway through
I stopped and I went and checked myself
into a hotel I got away from my family
for a while
and I realized I'm not living this way
either
I'm not doing some of these things that
I was writing about and I had to control
alt delete everything and so this book
is not me talking at you as so I'm like
I've got it all figured out this book is
me walking with you saying
we've created a world that our bodies
cannot exist in
and we've got to do something different
so look this book provides the six daily
choices that we all got to make to
overcome anxiety some of these are every
day some of these are every month some
of these are on an annual basis but
we've got choices to make about how we
live our lives they are practical
strategies I did not write a pop
psychology book and I also did not write
some super highly technical
jargon filled
um book for clinicians and researchers
how they talk to each other
this book is written for regular people
like you and me just trying to figure
out how to be a little bit better
parents how to stop the cycle of hurt
how to be less anxious how to come home
and create a home that is warm and full
of laughter and full of joy and this
crazy word that we don't even know what
it means anymore
peace this is the um as they say highly
anticipated follow-up to my number one
bestseller own your past change your
future I don't know how many people are
highly anticipating this except for
maybe my mom listen no matter where you
start
you're gonna gain a deep understanding
of what anxiety is what it's not I did
integrate some of the stuff from
redefining anxiety so if you picked up
that tiny quick read this is going to be
that book exploded and oh so much more
so much more listen anxiety doesn't have
to rule your life burn out chronic
stress all the things that we're dealing
with
there's an end point you can choose
something different all right the book
releases on October 3rd pre-stale starts
now so if you go pre-order the book
right now
20 bucks I'm gonna give you some of the
raddest bonus items so listen I want you
to get help today
so if you pre-order the book today that
talk that you just saw a piece of it I'm
going to send you the whole talk right
away instantly you're gonna have access
to the whole thing
and so much more pre-order today at John
deloney.com go to John deloney.com
building a non-anxious life I'm super
excited I want to get this into the
hands of everybody
my neighbors my friends and quite
honestly myself because we gotta do
something different and this is the map